Kevin McCarthy is officially out as the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
Mr McCarthy is the first speaker in
history to be ousted from the job by a
vote and he is out because Republican
Congressman Matt Gates led a rebellion
of just eight Republicans to vote
against the speaker what happens now
McCarthy wasn't great but he was far
from the worst in fact this is probably
damning with faint praise but it's still
true Kevin McCarthy is probably the most
conservative speaker that Republicans
have had since Joe Martin in the 1950s
he was certainly better than Paul Ryan
certainly better than John Boehner
arguably he was more conservative even
than Newt Gingrich but
he lost the trust of some key
conservatives so now he's out and now
there is a vacancy for the worst job in
all of American politics